In the future
Entertainment will be randomly generated
Randomly Generated?
rAndomly generated!
What better way to achieve the unexpected
I've seen the future Bob
And the future is
"Auto-Tainment"
*THE FUTURE IS NOW*
Hi *Rusty(?)*
Hi *Ventilamedic(?)*
Hi Larry!
Hi Bob!
Greetings
Hey, those are robots!
Affirmative
Not only that, but these guys represent the hosts of the future!
Unlike us, their humor can be truly randomly generated!
Right guys?
Why did the chicken cross the road?
I don't know! Why did the chicken cross the road
*Loading funny pun*
W̵̺̗̼̣͕̪̱̝̻̍̀̀͌́̚͢͝Ë̘̫̭̭͙̰̩̯́̑͋̄͐̀͘Ḛ͈̠̰͖͎̜̄̀̌̽̍́̂̓̚̕D͔̹͉͎͓̃̏̔̓̈́́̊̿͟ E̢̛̠̠͈̠͛̿̾͑̊̋͋͘͜͠ͅA̵͍̜̙̟̮͉̅̑͌͛̓̓̓͌̈́̇T̰̪̼̝̮͓̐̐̾̀͑͗̽̕͝͝Ḝ̵̧̥̹̗̯̱͔̥͍̍̒̍̀́R̖̥̤̙̲̙̞͗̿̇̀̒̓̓
*Laughter*
Now that's funny!
That doesn't make any sense!
It's funny because it's unexpected.
Well....
Whatever happened to "it's funny because it's true"?
2 + 2 = 4 is true, but not funny
Guys...
What is the solution to the equation 2 + 2?
I don't know, what does 2 + 2 equal?
*LOADING FUNNIEST PUN*
.
W̴̡̱͈̻͍̹̤̩̳̋̆͂̓̆ͅ E̢̤͙͔̰̠̺͚͎̋͊̌̉̍̌̎̀͘͝ Ē͎͇̖̃̏͗̈́̉̍͌͢͠ͅ D͍͙͔̙͈͙̙̦͐͐̂̀́̀́̕͘    Ȩ̷̬̙̦̩̮͙̞̪̒̃̅̑͘ A̶̡̗̦̬̙̻͗̎̋̔̊̄͡͠ T̴͉͕͎̳͍̞͕̮͓͛͐̔̂̓͋̔͑͟ E͚̳͇̱͕̠̾̀̋̏́̌̒̎̚̕ R̡̛̺͔͉̘̲̆͆̈̍͑̕͞ͅ
That's a good one